MALE SPEAKER: Welcome, Googlers.
I've got a really cool
speaker for you today.
So she's done some amazing
volunteer and work with NGOs
as a professional now
in Rwanda and Ghana,
and she's going to share the
stories of the people she works
with, but more importantly, how
she's found to make development
sustainable and not reliant just
on people swooping in and then
swooping out.
And I think that
the story should
tell a really poignant
and meaningful,
especially going into the
Googler Gives time of the year.
So with that, I'm going to
let Kelsey tell her story,
then we're going to switch
to a Q&A in little bit.
Kelsey?
KELSEY FINNEGAN: OK.
Hi everyone.
Thanks so much for having me.
I'm Kelsey Finnegan,
as James said,
and I am actually
from the Bay Area.
I'm from Dublin in the
East Bay, but I live now
in Kigali, Rwanda.
So I'm here today because
I want to tell you
about my work the last six
years in Ghana and Rwanda.
But I also hope that I can
give you some tangible examples
of ways that you
can be effective
if you want to do something
in the developing world.
So I think it's
important to point out
that I didn't start out
wanting to have this career.
I never dreamed of
living in Africa.
And when I was studying at UCSB,
I was studying communication,
and Africa and
international development
could not have been
further from my mind.
I was removed and
distant, and I assumed
that while it was unfortunate,
the circumstances and lives
of people on the other
side of the world
weren't inextricably
linked to mine.
I was a student.
I could barely pay
my rent on time.
I couldn't really
take care of myself,
so I assumed that
that meant that I was
powerless to help other people.
I didn't realize how wrong
I was until curiosity
and a free summer took me to
a volunteer trip in Ghana.
I was placed to be an assistant
teacher in a kindergarten
class.
And I, by the way, was
not a trained teacher.
Communication at UCSB
doesn't really give you that.
So I was given a class of
60 wild five-year-old kids,
and the teacher
that I was supposed
to be working with usually
used my presence as a way
to go get her hair
or nails done.
So for the most part,
I was on my own.
So I decided to
focus on literacy.
And we spent most of our time
on the alphabet and numbers.
So one day towards
the end of my trip,
I was assessing them to
see how far they actually
knew with their literacy.
And I was testing them on
letters of the alphabet.
And I realized
throughout the day
that actually, they had not
understood a single thing
that I'd taught them the entire
time that I had been there,
and that they had
just tricked me
into making it seem like they
knew what I was teaching them.
So I left that day, and then
I left Ghana a few days later,
and I was completely devastated.
I knew that if I had actually
known what I was doing,
I would have been able
to identify the problem
and help them.
But instead, I'd
wasted their time,
and even more so,
I'd also wasted mine
because they were going to
be moved up through a system.
They were going to graduate
to the next grade level.
And I realized that they
were going to consistently
be in a system that could
never teach them to read.
And instead of actually
being effective,
I had wasted two months
of their academic career.
And I was really upset
because it was very clear
that they were five years
old and the entire trajectory
of their lives had
already been decided.
So I had so wanted
to be effective,
but instead, my
presence had probably
left them in a worse state.
And a lot of that
was because I went
in with my own agenda
and assumptions of what
I thought that they needed.
So I went back to
the States, but I
found it really impossible
to resume normal life.
And I wanted to make it
right, and even more so, I
wanted to find a
way to actually help
the community in an effective
and sustainable way.
So I went back to
Ghana on my own,
and there I actually met
a woman named Elizabeth.
And so several years
before, Elizabeth
had started gathering
street children under a tree
and teaching them, and
eventually, her home
had turned into a
school and an orphanage.
But I was surprised by the state
that the kids were living in.
They struggled to
find food every day.
They didn't have any
infrastructure, didn't really
have books or pencils.
And a lot of people had passed
through this place, which
was called Happy
Kids Orphanage, a lot
of local and international
people, but all of them
had felt too overwhelmed
to actually help
Elizabeth improve it.
So we started working
together, and we
decided to work piece by piece.
So the children didn't have a
place to sleep at Happy Kids.
So that was our first goal.
And I didn't know
how to fund raise,
but I decided to take a
chance and sent out an e-mail
to family and friends.
And that ended up
getting us the money
that we needed to
build a dormitory.
And I went back a few months
later, and we built it.
And so once we
had the dormitory,
we obviously realized that they
needed more infrastructure.
They needed more ways
to actually sustain
the facility themselves.
And so we registered Happy
Kids Foundation as an NGO.
and we continued
to work together,
and we built a school
classroom by classroom.
I started to realize as we were
building this infrastructure
that they needed something
to sustain the added cost
of having that infrastructure.
So from that point on, every
time we built something,
we implemented an
income generating
project or an
empowering project that
would help the facility
sustain itself-- a livestock
program, a sewing program where
the kids not only learn skills
that can help them support
themselves after they leave us,
but it helps us to also
raise some small money
in the village.
We opened the first internet
cafe in the village.
We also do things that
aren't income generating
but are important.
So this is Hannah when she saw
the ocean for the first time
a few years ago.
So I know that it
would be really
easy to say that
I did all of this,
and that all of this progress
could be attributed to my being
there.
But that would be giving
you an incomplete story.
It's actually because
of this person,
and because of an
amazing team of people
that we have in Ghana.
I'm a part of it.
That's very true.
But it's important to
remember that all I did
was build an idea off
of Elizabeth's already
existing dream.
And that's something
that I learned
that was really
important, which was that
in order for development
to be effective,
it has to be locally driven.
So if you want to make an
impact, the best way to do it
is to find someone who is
doing what you want to do
and supporting them.
As my work and
experience evolved,
I became really interested
in post-conflict development,
and I ended up
getting an opportunity
to work in Rwanda with survivors
of the Rwandan genocide.
Rwanda, by the way, is one
of the most beautiful places
you will ever see.
But it's not known for that.
It's more known for its history,
which I hope most of you know.
In 1994, the genocide resulted
in an estimated 800,000
to a million people being
killed in just 100 days.
Rwanda is famous not
only for the fact
that all of these
horrific things happened,
but also for the
conscious decision
of the international
community not to stop it.
At Survivors Fund, we work with
local survivors organizations,
and we work through
those local organizations
to support survivors
to access justice,
to gain skills that can help
them start small businesses,
for education,
and for counseling
among many other things.
This is a counseling
group that we have.
This is an income
generating group
meeting to go over
their accounting books.
So being in Rwanda,
I've had the privilege
of working with really
incredible people.
These people are
those who have managed
to survive not only
against the odds,
but they also are committed to
not being defined or limited
by what happened in 1994.
They consistently stand
up to improve themselves
and to improve
their communities,
despite the fact
that a lot of them
are still struggling with
the consequences of genocide.
One of those women is Josee.
In 1994, Josee was living with
her husband and three children.
And when the genocide started
and the extremists launched
the campaign to exterminate
the Tutsis and moderate Hutu,
her family was targeted.
So her husband and her son
were immediately killed,
but she managed to escape with
her children and her sister.
And they found refuge in
a family friend's home.
So while they thought
that they were
in a place that was
protecting them,
it turned out the man
that was protecting them
raped Josee and her sister.
So they fled again.
And despite the odds and despite
consistently being targeted,
Josee managed to survive.
And unfortunately,
soon after her sister
realized that she was pregnant
with the child of the rapist,
and these children in Rwanda
are typically referred
to as children of bad memories.
So because her sister
was so traumatized,
she was unable to
take care of the baby.
So Josee adopted her.
She felt that she
was really sick,
but she didn't really know
why, and several years passed.
And then in 1996,
Survivors Fund partnered
with another women's association
to launch a project that
gave free HIV testing.
And it was then
that Josee realized
that she was HIV positive.
So she wasn't able
to access medication
because it was really
expensive at that time,
and she was unable
to work or really do
much of anything for 10 years.
But eventually, she
got access to treatment
and became able to work.
So a lot of what we
do at Survivors Fund
is providing income
generating skills,
because a huge
number of survivors
are still living
in extreme poverty.
So we provide training
so that these people can
start their own small
microbusinesses.
And Josee participated in one
of those trainings in 2012,
and then she received a
loan to start a business.
She had prepared this
great business plan.
It seemed like everything
was going to plan,
and then he gave her the
money, and the moment we left,
she turned to her son
and she said, come.
Let's spend this money before
the killers come back for us.
This was 18 years
after the genocide.
So you can imagine how deeply
embedded that type of trauma
is.
And that is what trauma
in Rwanda still is today.
It's still very much there.
So once Survivor's Fund
learned about this,
we invited Josee to be a
part of a counseling group
that we run for women with
children born from rape.
And she went
through the program,
and she developed
another business plan.
And when she finished, we
gave her a second chance,
and she got a loan.
And that time she used
it for a business.
First it was chickens.
She's the true entrepreneur.
It was chickens.
Then it was goats.
And then it moved
into basket weaving.
Now, Josee runs
several businesses,
and she also goes
around the village
and teaches others
income generating skills
like basket weaving.
Josee's a really good
example because Rwanda
has made a lot of
progress since 1994,
and that can't be understated.
The government has put in place
so many incredible policies
to try and rebuild the country.
But there's also still
a lot of challenges
that survivors specifically
are struggling with.
And Josee is also an
example of the potential
that individuals have to create
solutions to their own poverty
if only they're given
the opportunity.
I realize that we can at
times feel overwhelmed
by the breath of
catastrophes happening today,
and maybe it's hard for
you to decide how or where
to lend your support.
But we can't shy away
from harsh realities,
because it's only in recognizing
them that we can actually
do something about it.
I think we're so often
paralyzed by the idea
that we as individuals are
too small or inconsequential
to actually affect any
sort of real change.
And I want to end my
presentation by telling you
that that assumption is wrong.
If my story demonstrates
anything, it's that none of us
are powerless to do
something, regardless
of the scale of the problem.
And you should choose
something that you believe in,
work to understand
it, and then find
someone locally who's working
to address it and support them.
Lastly, we have
to be optimistic,
both about the state of the
world and our existence in it.
These are the two
organizations that I
work with if anyone is
interested in learning
more information.
MALE SPEAKER: So it's
been over 20 years.
I think it's almost 21 now,
since the genocide in Rwanda.
Yet for many Rwandans, the
effects continue to haunt.
And you spoke about this with
a really pointed example.
What have you learned
about the long-term impact
of horrific events like this
from your work supporting
survivors?
KELSEY FINNEGAN: I
think that that's
one of the most confusing and
maybe sometimes surprising
thing for people to
realize, is that Rwanda
is, by all definition,
a success story
and has really come
a long way from 1994.
But it takes a lot
longer than 21 years
to actually recover
from genocide.
The consequences that
survivors are feeling
continue to change, and
in some cases, evolve.
In the immediate
aftermath of the genocide,
the priorities were
very different.
A lot of that was
on infrastructure.
Actually finding a
place to bury bodies
was a huge problem,
HIV, AIDS, counseling,
establishing a
secure police force
so that it secured the country.
Now, the challenges are
in some cases the same,
like Josee's story,
in terms of trauma
still being very
present in there,
but also being very different.
For example, women
that had children
that were born from rape
who are now growing up
into adulthood face issues
with identity and who they are.
The projects that
I work with support
young survivors who were
children during the genocide
and have grown up
for the most part
without social
support or family.
And they graduate
from school but find
that they're unable to find any
sort of job or access finance
that would help them
start a small business.
There's a lot of legal issues
related to the genocide,
and specifically with youth
who their parents had land
during the genocide,
and then they
have now grown up and
realized that they rightfully
should have land that
belonged to their families.
And that's a huge
asset in Rwanda
because it's a very
overpopulated country.
So they need legal support
to fight those battles
and to actually get
their land back.
And we run a legal and
counselling helpline program
that tries to support
people to do that.
Obviously, like I said, extreme
poverty is still an issue.
The opportunities for work are
still very limited in Rwanda.
So the challenges are
very multifaceted,
and they also continue to
evolve as time goes on,
which is why we
think and believe
that it needs a
targeted approach.
MALE SPEAKER: So I want
to switch gears back
to Happy Kids.
I think you've told me
some stories over the years
about introducing the
internet and computers to kids
for the first time.
What have you learned
about the impact of access
to the internet and
technology, both positively
and potentially negatively?
KELSEY FINNEGAN: We opened
the first internet cafe
in the village, which was
really interesting to see.
From an organizational
perspective,
it was huge for us in terms
of being able to communicate
with the outside world,
being able to advocate
for what we are
doing, learn lessons
from other organizations.
It was huge in that sense.
What I think was
probably more huge
was the impact it had
on the kids themselves.
Just in general, I was shocked
by how quickly they picked up
on the technology.
They fix my computer
now when there's
a problem, which is pretty
impressive because they've
had almost no training in it.
But it's also enabled them
to see outside of the village
and see really the possibilities
that they could have
despite being where they are.
One example is when
we first started
it and I had all these really
idealistic dreams about only
using the internet as
an educational resource.
And they were baiting me.
Kelsey, we've seen Facebook.
We really want Facebook.
You are too young.
They were like 14 at the time.
I said, this is going to
be an educational resource.
So I left the internet cafe,
and like 20 minutes later
I had 10 friend requests.
So I lost that battle.
Our kids are also growing up.
I was there a few
weeks ago, and you
have situations where teenage
boys are using the internet
that teenage boys
use the internet for.
That's been a really awkward,
hilarious thing to witness.
But that's what's so
cool is it kind of
enabled them to be normal
kids, which was a really
incredible thing to watch.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool.
At Happy Kids now, you
provide donors the option
of sponsoring a child.
And there are numerous
programs that do this.
Describe how that
works at Happy Kids
and what you've learned, at
least in your own experience,
about making that an
effective giving option.
KELSEY FINNEGAN:
In the beginning,
I actually shied away from
the sponsorship program
because I really
wanted to emphasize
on that local solution
and finding the way
to build up resources locally.
But raising that many
kids, which we have 40,
is always going to
be really expensive.
So we introduced
sponsorship as a way
to make sure that we can secure
basic needs for every kid.
So typically, the
person will either
choose the child-- we have
their profiles on our website--
so they can choose the child
or we can choose them for them.
And then with us, because
we're a small organization,
we really do connect that
individual to that child.
That doesn't always happen
with sponsorship programs.
But with us, we really wanted
it to be mutually beneficial,
both for the kid themselves
and also for the person
that chooses to sponsor them.
So when they link up,
normally the sponsor
will write a letter.
And then if we can,
when we can, the kids
will write back, which
has been hilarious.
Because we really just
hand them a piece of paper
and tell them to write.
And so we have
really great letters
that they write
about their lives,
and then we have
others that are written
by six-year-olds that are
like, "Dear Jonathan, I
love flowers."
And that's it.
So that's been
really entertaining.
But I was surprised by how much
it ended up meaning to the kids
personally, how
much they actually
value having a sponsor.
And I can only speak
for our program
because we really make
that effort to make
them understand where the
support is coming from.
I think in general with
sponsorship programs,
the support doesn't
just go to that child,
and ours is the same.
It supports that
child, but it also
helps us just run
the organization
and try to improve
on what we're doing.
So I think any
time that you want
to be involved in
sponsorship, you should also
be connected to what the
organization's mission is,
because either way your support
is going to affect both.
MALE SPEAKER: CNN's
Anderson Cooper
has spoken of telling stories
of people who would otherwise
be invisible and forgotten.
And he had a great quote
that I couldn't track down
during the tsunami that affected
Indonesia, where there were
people that just existed,
then didn't exist, and would
have been completely wiped
off the history of the earth.
So what have you learned about
from the individual people,
their stories, and your
years in Ghana and Rwanda
that you'll take with you
for the rest of your life?
KELSEY FINNEGAN: I think
it's really important
to tell those individual
stories because that's
what makes it relatable.
I think we can so often get
bogged down by the broader
numbers and all
these catastrophes
that we can't really relate to,
and telling an individual story
humanizes problems or successes.
And so I realized
that it was really
crucial to tell those
stories in order
to help people connect with
things that are maybe very far
away and foreign to them.
When I went to see
Josee a few weeks ago
and asked her if she was OK
with me telling her story today,
she was very calm and she
said, please, go and tell them.
And I think with that, it's
a very good example of how
a lot of people in
Rwanda, as difficult
as it is to tell
their story, they
want it to be shared because
they're so desperate to have
people realize what
happened, and also realize
the mistake that all
of us made and why
it shouldn't happen again.
I think it's also
important to say, though,
that you're not only sharing
stories of doom and despair.
And I try to do that a lot.
I try to not always show
pictures of sad people
because that's not
how Africa is defined,
and genocide certainly isn't
all that Rwanda is defined as.
And so it's also important
to share positive stories
and to make sure that it doesn't
create a negative image when
it's not the full story.
MALE SPEAKER: Just
one more question
before I open up the audience.
For most people, the
ability to help and support
those outside their communities
is limited to donations.
What have you learned working
for charitable organizations
that can help
individuals channel
their donations in the most
effective and impactful way
possible?
KELSEY FINNEGAN: That's what I'm
hoping that you could take away
from this, is that
you realize that you
don't have to go to Africa
or volunteer in Africa
to make some sort of impact.
Actually, for most of
you, it's probably better
that you support from here.
You can actually make more
of an impact from here.
And a lot of that is
through supporting
local people or
local organizations,
which is what we do
at Survivors Fund.
It's what we do at
Happy Kids, building up
the capacity of local
people, which really makes
sure that the projects are being
determined by the people who
actually need them and not
by the donors themselves.
I think it's also
really important
to be flexible and open,
because sometimes the causes
or projects that could benefit
from your support the most
are maybe not so attractive.
If you find an organization
or an individual
that you think is
really doing good,
giving them the flexibility
to use your money
as they see best fit will make
your money go much further.
AUDIENCE: It's so interesting.
You make a differentiation about
if you want to make an impact,
find somebody who is doing
what you are interested in
and support them.
And I feel like that's
an important shift
that-- I don't know.
Do you see that taking place
in the developing world
right now, where we're starting
to support local organizations?
Because I feel like what
was happening before
was we'd show up with
our ideas and make
our suggestions and
our money, and we'd
try to fix things for people,
and that that wasn't working.
And when you talked
about going to the school
and how you spent two months
at it and that didn't work,
I just wonder if that
shift is happening
or if you still see people
showing up and trying
to fix things on their own.
KELSEY FINNEGAN: Good question.
I think that development
itself is really advancing.
I think a lot of
people have this idea
of what development used to
be, and that can sometimes
be ineffective.
I think that the way
it's going is definitely
on building local institutions
and having local partners.
It is worth saying, though,
that that's really difficult
because it takes time to build
the capacity of organizations
and to make sure that
they also play a part
in the design of a project.
I would say in Ghana,
it happens more often
that people just
kind of jump in,
at least in the village,
and some people who maybe
have development as a hobby.
But it is a very
professional sector,
and I think it's
better to support
experts that are
on the ground that
are working with local people.
And it doesn't necessarily
mean that you only
support local
institutions, but make sure
that whatever organization
you're supporting
is working with a
local institution
and trying to make the work
more sustainable that way.
So I think it's kind of both.
I do think we're going
in that direction,
but it's definitely the
more difficult way to do it.
So it's a slow
progression, I think.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
I want to thank
Kelsey and everyone
on the live stream for however
many there are-- I always
have no idea who's out there--
and everyone that's going
to see this later on YouTube.
So thank you very much,
Kelsey, for sharing
your story and the story
of those you work with.
Appreciate it, and
found it very moving.
Thank you.
KELSEY FINNEGAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]